now we're going to take the ideas from
the last video and learn how to sketch
in these Exponential's really rapidly
now I want to move this up and we'll do
some couple of examples here's an
example circuit I've already set up
it's an RC circuit this is 1000 ohms and
this is 2 micro farad capacitor and this
voltage source provides a step voltage
to us it's going to start out at 1 volt
and then step rapidly down to 0 volts at
time equals 0 and then again at 10
milliseconds it'll step up again to 1
volt and continue on that way
this could be a clock in a circuit and
in a digital circuit or it could be any
kind of a digital signal and our what we
want to know is we want to find this
voltage right here what does that look
like we're going to use what we know
about our C waveforms to tell us what's
going to happen here really quickly we
don't need to use a computer to simulate
this all right so first thing I need to
know is what's the RC time constant so
RC equals 1000 1k times 2 micro farad's
and that equals to K times K is plus 3
micro is minus 6 so this is 2 times 10
to the minus 3 or 2 milliseconds so I
can actually go over right here to my
chart and I can put a spot right here at
2 milliseconds right there there's 5
milliseconds
there's 5 there's there's a rat about 2
and real rapidly what I know is that
that line is going to look roughly like
this it's going to start of course it's
going to start right here and that line
is going to go right through here so let
me see if I can just sketch that in
that's about what that is going to look
like now on the other side when it goes
up when it goes up it's going to start
here and it's going to go up to where
it's going to go to more milliseconds 1
2
is about two more milliseconds that's
the final value of that voltage and I
can draw another line here like this I
can sketch that in and the same thing is
going to happen over here as soon as
that goes down I go two milliseconds
over it's going to go right through
about there start here and down I go now
let me let me get a little more exact
what I want to do now is is do a little
better job of sketching in this
exponential curve and we know that it's
about 37% right about there here's about
37% of the starting voltage right there
so that now I just use my sketching
skills and I just smooth in some kind of
curve that looks like that and on the
other side
I come down 37% which is roughly right
about there and I can draw again I can
just sketch this in and that will come
up to some value there finishing value
and the same thing here I go 37% up the
exponential is going to go through that
so it's going to come down and then
curve off like this and that's going to
be my estimate now I didn't use a
computer to do that how do we know if it
got it right well I did use a computer
once so here's what it's going to look
like let me turn that on and we'll move
it up a little bit and we can compare
what we got I simulated this in Excel
just using the equations to get a really
precise answer and what you notice is
our sketch looks pretty good it looks
pretty close to that
so what we're comparing is compare this
to that and that's that's pretty similar
that's not bad and that tells me that
our output signal our voltage on the
capacitor is following the digital
signal fairly well and it's reaching its
high level and is rapidly coming down as
fast as it can so let me do one more let
me do one more problem and we'll change
the capacitor value
now what the change here the change here
is for microfarads this is still 1k this
is 4 micro farad so RC let's do it again
real fast
RC equals 1 K times 4 micro farad's and
that equals 4 milliseconds so now I know
that the time constants 4 milliseconds
that means I know that my that straight
line sketch here's 5 milliseconds it go
through right about here I start up here
I can dress I can sketch in a straight
line like that it goes roughly like that
same thing over here I can go out
another 4 milliseconds up like that and
sketch you in my slope and we'll do the
third one over here here's 4
milliseconds after the change is right
about there and I sketch the line in and
now we'll go back and do our 37% trick
which is 37% is right about there and
will come up it goes through right there
and if I sketch it in now what's going
to happen is it's going to go through
that and something over there is going
to happen I don't know if it's going to
finish it might it might not this one's
going to go up same way
let's do 37% down it's about there
accurate enough and we'll sketch in this
line and then we'll do the same thing
over here up 37% and down we go now let
me show you the the answer that I
calculated with a computer and we'll see
how that looks
let's move it up
and we did pretty well notice how the
notice how down here notice how down in
this area here we sort of got it that's
pretty accurate I missed a little bit up
here that's okay that's okay but with
that time constant we can notice right
away that this this this waveform is at
risk of not making it all the way down
to the final value before it's asked to
turn up and go around the other way so
that kind of intuition that kind of
understanding of an exponential curve
really makes you very quick you can do
this manually and in your head you can
sketch out what these Exponential's look
like the time point here this this line
right here that's RC seconds after it
drops that's the basic thing and then
the other one is this point right here
that's about 37% of where it started
from
37% to go so that's just a nice little
skill to have when you're looking at
Exponential's which you do all the time
if you're designing computers or any
other kind of circuit that has sudden
changes in voltage like we had here